trouble brett mike thank you
multiple media reports including one
anaxio says
say house minority leader kevin mccarthy
will talk
about social media posts with georgia
republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene recent reports
show comments from green's facebook
account
that referred to the execution of senior
democrats and the endorsement of
conspiracy theories linked to qanon
axios saying mccarthy has referred to
green's comments as disturbing
a spokesperson with his office saying he
will speak directly
to her about them green issued a
statement suggesting other people had
access to her facebook account and not
all of the comments
represented her views also tonight
california democratic congressman jimmy
gomez says
he is introducing a resolution to have
green expelled
from the house up next an exclusive
conversation with former iranian
president
mahmoud ahmadinejad about wanting a seat
at the table
in dealing with the new american biden
administration